hey youtubers it's Charlie so huge news
James Gunn and Kevin Feige just
confirmed the title of guardians of the
galaxy to is vol 2 as an awesome mix vol
2 it's just a play on the irreverent
mixtape theme of the first movies that
means you get the point it's guardians
of the galaxy - but it's vol 2 because
it's awesome mix vol 2 the way James
Gunn confirmed it - is kind of funny
technically Kevin Feige did it last
night at a press Q and a for ant-man but
not a lot of people realized what
happened until this morning
so when I saw James Gunn make the
comment I was like is this is this a
joke is this easy just kidding because
it doesn't sound like a real title but
now that I think about it in the context
of the awesome makes I think it totally
works they'll be shooting guardians
pretty soon James Gunn has already
offered up some details about it namely
there will be no Hulk like you know no
Hulk in space anytime soon no Nova
there'll be a new member of the
guardians team and in the movie
thematically we'll deal with the issue
of shitty space dads maybe not all of
them will be shitty but I just like the
idea of thinking that a better way to
say it would be fathers and their
children will be a big theme in the
movie but I'd like the idea of shitty
space dads could you have fan o's shitty
space dad you have Star Wars dad who's
gonna be a shitty space dad turns out in
the Marvel Universe when you have a kid
in space you will be a terrible father
even Odin who's a hero is kind of a
terrible dad most of the time the comics
paint him is a pretty big dick for
everyone still wondering about Peter
Quill's father best thoughts right now
are that it's starfox
there will be more humanoids in the film
but no more humans from Earth so it like
don't expect Captain Marvel guardians is
one of those franchises that Marvel has
that's so different looking and feeling
from the other Marvel movies and it's
been so successful they're just gonna
leave James Gunn and those guys off by
themselves to build that universe out a
little bit more before they cross over
so don't expect any end of the Avengers
to show up at least until the third
movie Avengers infinity war all bets are
off Kevin Feige James Gunn of all set
yeah definitely
everybody has to meet at a certain point
that's endgame but that is like a long
ways off in the distance one of the
really fun things about Marvel's press Q
as for movies is that they also talked a
lot about the other movies so we learned
a bunch of things about the rest of
phase 3 going down the list let's start
with Spider Man just because everybody's
been talking about Tom Holland recently
they're still trying to
you're out who the villain is going to
be for the first spider-man movie
they're not doing the Uncle Ben origin
story so I'm not expecting them to
repeat villains that we've seen recently
either Veneman symbiote feels like a
couple steps away I mean there's just
like so many classic villains they
haven't done yet like you have the
vulture
yeah Mysterio like I mean you know there
are several big villains they could do
before they go back to venom venom is
that character that you march out when
spider-man starts to get really dark
himself where he starts looking at
himself and he goes wow I have crossed
the line here and when we meet Peter
Parker for the first time he's gonna be
like 15 in Captain America Civil War
then by the time he gets that first
spider-man movie he'll be 16 so he's not
ready to be super dark yet at worst he
will be a little bit emo but not like
Tobey Maguire levels of emo next up on
the list the Mandarin still in the
Marvel Universe if you remember the
shorts they did after Iron Man 3 it just
suggested that the 10 rings and Mandarin
were real people
even though Bank Kingsley was an
imposter during Iron Man 3 so he's still
out there somewhere Marvel isn't quite
ready to use him yet Marvel has a bit of
an issue with that character because for
most of his history in the comics he's a
bit of a racist stereotype Marvel really
likes to release films in China and
they're very particular about movies
they let into the country they only let
20 American films in per year and it's
like it's like a billion-dollar industry
so if they feel like there's something
racist in a movie they're not gonna let
it in so when the Mandarin does
eventually show up don't expect him to
look exactly like he does in the comics
and no Robert Downey jr. has pretty much
said that there is no Iron Man 4 on the
books right now next up Captain America
Civil War so Mark Ruffalo made this
weird comment where he was like well if
Robert Downey jr. sysm in the movie I
guess I'm in the movie like he didn't
know whether or not he was in like where
is Hulk during Civil War Kevin Feige
clarified that comment that Mark Ruffalo
made he said Hulk is not a primary part
of civil war he may not be part at all
people are just taking that to mean that
he might actually have like a really
small part in it like a really small
cameo Civil War the movie is kind of
like Avengers 2.5 in that it just has so
many characters in it when you look at
the massive list of characters that
Marvel has done in movies before
those are involved with civil war in
some way it makes sense because in the
comics almost every single Marvel
character was in it if you guys have
ever been to Disney's d23 this is also
like the year to do that because Kevin
Feige said they might be bringing some
footage from Civil War to that they've
been shooting the movie for a couple
months now so they actually do have
enough footage to show off and enough
footage to build a trailer
don't be surprised if the first civil
war trailer drops in August like the
first promo I'm expecting them to attach
a really big trailer to Star Wars in
December but that prior released
something way before that
moving on to ant-man Kevin Feige said
that they might be doing a sequel before
Avengers infinity wars over like they
might put an extra movie on the books
they've already announced all their
phase 3 movies but they might change
that line up just a little bit depending
on the success of ant-man like if it
does really well they'll fast-track a
sequel
they've already been some spoilers about
the post-credits scenes there's a
mid-credits scene and then there's like
an after the credits scene so be sure to
stay through the entire credits whenever
you go see it and please do not post
those post credits spoilers ant-man
itself isn't like a huge springboard for
the other Marvel movies in the way that
the Avengers movies always are but there
is a lot of setup for Doctor Strange in
it too so pay attention it's not quite
as literal as like an actual scene like
I'm not expecting Doctor Strange to show
up in the movie but somatically there is
some weirdness in ant-man that will give
you an idea for the weirdness of Doctor
Strange as a movie they actually just
went to England to start shooting Doctor
Strange so I'll probably start hearing
more about that movie throughout the
rest of the year and then just speaking
about the TV universe he was mostly
referring to daredevil but Kevin Feige
also confirmed that TV characters would
start showing up in the movies
eventually it's long been rumored that
the defenders would show up in Avengers
infinity war not the defenders is still
a long ways off we still have to do Luke
Cage Jessica Jones and iron fist but do
not be surprised if the street-level
hero team-up shows up in the big
blockbuster superhero team-up
infinity war it's gonna be like like the
biggest Marvel party they've ever done
on screen they're gonna send invites to
everybody it'll be like an RSVP for the
end of the universe before you know
Thanos does his finger snap and wipes
out half the universe just speaking
about that too I would be totally
surprised if the Infinity Gauntlet goes
down
the exact same way it does in the comics
where Thanos is like I'm courting death
I'm gonna kill half the universe in one
finger snap that's part of the classic
Infinity Gauntlet storyline a big part
of that is the hero's figuring out how
to bring back the half of the universe
that they a knows kills I'm expecting
movie infinity war to be way simpler
than that and I don't know that we will
see the cosmic entity death it just
depends on how trippy they get with Thor
Ragnarok and guardians of the galaxy -
those are like the only space-based
movies we have right now so if you see a
bunch of really weird cosmic stuff in
those movies I you know I think it'll
give us a good idea of how weird
infinity war it's gonna get so that's a
whole lot of news let me know what do
you think about the idea of guardians of
the galaxy to being called vol 2 I know
a lot of you guys are asking about
awesome mix - dick James Gunn has
already picked the tracklist he hasn't
announced that yet though he said that
was one of the first things he did like
before he wrote the screenplay
he picked what awesome mix two is going
to be we got a tease for that at the end
of guardians 1 it was the gift that his
mother gave him that he never opened so
lots of Marvel stuff happening this
morning that there was another Marvel
video that I was working on so I'll just
I'll do that next after I do my Game of
Thrones Q&A it's just gonna be about
Marvel movies set in the past because
Kevin Feige said that they're probably
gonna do another movie like Captain
America the First Avenger that takes
place entirely in the past my best
theory about that just off the top of my
head is that it would be Inhumans or it
would be like some another new IP that
they haven't done yet they could always
do a movie for an existing franchise
like like Iron Man or Captain America or
even Thor and set that way way in the
past entirely but I don't think that
they would do that right away I think if
they were gonna do movie set in the past
it would you know be with relatively
minor characters it would be some sort
of new IP it would really be fun to see
war of kings set in like the past in the
distant past of the galaxy which does
kind of make it sound like Star Wars you
know a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away but Disney does own both franchises
so they can rip each other off as much
as they want so let me know if Marvel
does a movie set in the past what do you
want them to do rumor it has to entirely
take place in the past so don't forget
Game of Thrones Q&A coming tonight be
sure to subscribe to get that in the
meantime just in case you haven't seen
it I did a Game of Thrones video
yesterday all about the history
house Tyrell you can click here to learn
all about that and you can click here to
learn all about guardians of the galaxy
2 and what James Gunn is said about it
so far thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you